hey youtubers it's Charlie and the BBC
just confirmed we're getting a 2015
Sherlock Christmas special I know you
all wanted to get a Christmas special
this year but Benedict Cumberbatch and
Martin Freeman are way too busy but
since we do have an actual date for
winter Bert Setlock is going to be
happening again I'm gonna be doing some
special Sherlock bonus videos whenever
we get to December especially around the
Doctor Who Christmas special so be sure
to subscribe to get everything
December is gonna be like a month for
Doctor Who and Sherlock it'll be great
so here's the details Cumberbatch and
Freeman will film the 2015 Christmas
special this coming January January 2015
that is later in 2015 they'll film the
three new episodes for series 4 those
will aired January 2016 so it's just
like series 3 we get a Christmas special
leading into a new series it's gonna be
awesome so yes it is a bummer that we
won't be getting new episodes for almost
a year and a half but do not forget
about Setlock if you're not familiar
with the term it defines a group of fans
that patrol the set of Sherlock whenever
they're filming it's part of the fandom
that camps out and live tweets pictures
and updates Tumblr posts whenever actual
production is happening so if you really
enjoy talking to other Sherlock fans
Setlock is more of like a world cup for
you than the actual world cup I will be
making special videos while Setlock is
going on in addition to this stuff I'm
going to be doing in December so we'll
have Setlock going on in January 2015
whatever they film the Christmas special
and then again during the spring and
summer whenever they're filming the
actual episodes when they film Sherlock
series 3 what ended up happening is is
they filmed two episodes and then they
had to go on a break and then come back
and film the third episode much much
later in the year that was because
Martin Freeman had to go back and finish
filming The Hobbit they came back in
August to film that third episode his
last vow and it all worked out so don't
be surprised if something like that
happens again
but I think they're gonna try and film
all three episodes back-to-back it's way
harder when they're making television to
just do a little bit of it and then go
away and try and bring everyone back
from all over the world and try and do
that last a little bit it takes about
three months for them to film edit and
finish an episode so they're going to
have to finish all the filming of series
four by the end of August if they're
gonna make the January first
airdate and be able to release a new
episode every week that's been the
schedule in the past so I think that
they're gonna maintain that when we get
this series four they're just gonna air
the first episode January 1st and then
each week after that the only big change
that
happen since series three is that
they've shortened the international
window that people have to wait so if
you live in an outside country you want
to wait as long to see the episodes for
example in the United States instead of
airing on BBC America like Doctor Who
Sherlock airs on PBS and for whatever
reason they still have to wait a few
weeks to air the episodes after they air
on BBC one so if you do want to watch
Sherlock at the earliest possible time
you either have to watch it on BBC one
or in the iPlayer that can be kind of
tricky if you don't live in the UK but I
will explain some suggestions for non UK
people whenever we get there it's like a
year and a half away so do not worry so
now let's talk a little bit about what
the story of the Christmas special is
gonna be because they did use that
Andrew Scott picture at the end of his
last vow there's a couple of directions
they could go the series is jump forward
and backward in time teased alternate
versions of scenes like the rooftop fall
and it's even gone full-on mind Palace
where Sherlock plays out whole scenes
just in his mind plus we have to
remember the state we left things in at
the end of his last vow like Mycroft
rescinding Sherlock's exile and how the
previous Christmas special dealt with
that jump in time between series two and
three I am expecting the period of time
between series 3 in series 4 to be about
the same at the end of his last vow Mary
was pregnant with girl Sherlock will
just call her that for now Watson and
Sherlock seemed like they were in a much
more stable place emotionally and
Sherlock himself seemed much more
accepting of his survival odds and the
black ops mission Mycroft as well the
understanding was is that Sherlock
probably was not gonna survive past six
months I do suspect that Mycroft would
have found a way to extract Sherlock
again just like he did at the beginning
of empty hearse I think if Sherlock had
gone through with the mission they gave
him we would have seen the exact same
type of scenario play out you know
Mycroft casually revealing himself as
Sherlock gets ready to be tortured I
think that Steven Moffat and Mark Gatiss
are really good at teasing things and
then yanking you in the other direction
which is why they you know put Sherlock
on the plane but then showed you
Moriarty's face there are a couple big
things I think are gonna happen during
that in-between time and the series for
Christmas special will probably be just
like the series 3 Christmas special it
won't pick up right there on the tarmac
it's gonna jump forward in time a little
bit I think the most obvious thing that
means is that Mary will have had her
baby already she was pretty much ready
to pop on the tarmac right there I do
hope the special ends up showing the
baby and if we
you see the birth I think it's gonna be
done in flashback I feel like the naming
of the baby will be something that they
include too they'll just end the special
at the point where they can start that
first episode in series four or they're
like this happy little family you know
two people with two babies like one real
small one and one big grumpy one so what
about the mystery of the Moriarty clip
playing on all the screens over London
if they jump forward in time the likely
have generated a list of suspects that
Sherlock and Mycroft will be vetting
probably mostly Sherlock
I love seeing Mycroft out in the field
during series three but that was a huge
deal his character in the books would
have never done that in the books
Mycroft seems more like the kind of
person who would never leave his office
or the Diogenes Club for anything even
Sherlock Gatiss his version of the
character seems much friendlier in
contrast if not friendly in general at
least when he's around Sherlock so I
already did a series for predictions
video talking about stories they might
be able to do like valley of fear lady
Frances CARFAX dying detective
red-headed league those could be the
basis of full episodes but what's the
story the Christmas special gonna be
last year special was just like a short
video I don't really consider it an
episode the BBC didn't reveal how long
the special would be but it sounds like
it's gonna be somewhere in between just
because they'll have to address the
Moriarty clip and the baby I don't think
they're gonna use it to set up the main
villain or any of the big stories that
are gonna do for each of the episodes
but I do have a few ideas on who that
villain could be the only thing the BBC
has said officially is that it's someone
or something that fans will never expect
and I do have a few theories about that
right away it makes me think they're
gonna bring back Andrew Scott
full on and he'll play the true Moriarty
and they'll just reveal that the
Moriarty from series 1 & 2 was the
brother in case you're confused about
this in the Canon Arthur Conan Doyle was
not super great at coming up with new
names for characters so Professor
Moriarty the arch villain of the books
had a brother named Colonel James
Moriarty so why they were both named
James Moriarty we have no idea but one
was professor and one was colonel it
could have been because Doyle didn't
care enough to come up with a better
name or it could have just been an
oversight but if they do want to use him
Moffat and Gatos have a spare James
Moriarty lying around in the Canon so in
case you haven't seen any of the
interviews with Gatiss and Moffat they
draw on all Sherlock Canon or I guess
you could say they canonize all
things Sherlock so it's not just the
books they also included a bunch of
stuff from basil Rathbones Sherlock as
well as the radio plays Doctor Who fans
will remember that Moffat did the same
thing for the Doctor Who 50th
anniversary special he canonized the
radio dramas the Doctor Who radio dramas
whenever Paul McGann's eighth doctor
called out a bunch of names of the radio
characters during the night of the
doctor mini episode it was really cool
so whenever you start dari crafting
about Sherlock series four make sure you
think about all things Sherlock not just
the original books a couple of villains
they could use might include the true
version of Colonel Moran Gaydos actually
changed the book character and gave his
name to the politician in empty hearse
so technically you could say he wasn't
the real Colonel Moran then there's
Henry Peter from the Lady carfax story
Renee her on phantom Oz and van bork
they could also do the same thing that
they did in empty hearse where they take
a character's name and just mix and
match with villains I know a lot of
Doctor Who fans argue that Moffat gets
timey wimey with Doctor Who canon but
whenever it comes to Sherlock they are
pretty faithful to their big villain
characters it's usually just the lesser
characters that they mess around with
Billy Wiggins is actually a good example
that he's the combination of two
characters from the books there was a
Billy character in a Wiggins character
Billy was Holmes pageboy featured in
valley of fear and Wiggins was the
leader of Holmes's Baker Street
Irregulars but now it's your turn let me
know in the comments what are you most
excited to see in these new Sherlock
episodes and let me know your theories
are on that Moriarty clip so I won't
have time to do a Q&A for this so I'll
just try and answer everyone in the
comments if you have questions but I
will be doing a bunch of Sherlock in
December when we get closer to the
Doctor Who Christmas special and when
they actually start filming the Sherlock
Christmas special in January so it'll be
a lot of fun be sure to subscribe to get
everything there is a whole lot of
Doctor Who stuff coming though series 8
is premiering in August so get excited
about that right now click here to get
my breakdown in the series 8 trailer and
click here to get all my Sherlock series
4 predictions thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
you